Hi, my name is Zareen Choudhury.
And I'm a master's student
in electrical engineering
and computer science.
And for my master's
research, I've
been working in the networks
at MIT group in C-cell.
The main technology
that our group works on
is a device called WiTrack
which is a wall mounted
IoT device that uses
radio signals to monitor
various things of people
in the environment,
such as their breathing,
sleeping, and walking patterns.
Now in order to
actually use this device
and deploy it in
people's homes there
are two main components that
first need to be configured,
which are connecting the
device to a wireless network
for internet connectivity
and specifying
the boundaries in
which the device is
allowed to collect data.
Now unfortunately, the
pre-existing methods
for configuring both
of these components
was very difficult to
use, required experts,
and was not always reliable.
So for my project.
I built the first configuration
system for WiTrack
for both wireless connectivity
and physical boundaries.
And I focused on making
this system easy to use,
not requiring experts, as well
as being reliable and robust.
And as of now,
we've successfully
deployed the wireless
configuration system
in over a dozen homes with
successful and positive
feedback.
And we are currently
in the process
of running user studies
for the configuration
for physical boundaries.